[Music]
let's go out to Glendale Arizona and
talk to Kylie what's up
Kylie hi Dr John thank you so much for
taking my call of course what's
up uh not too much just kind of been
anticipating this and I'm kind of
nervous so well just pull up a seat and
grab some nachos and we can hang out
it's all good what's up that sounds good
um so my original question that I sent
in was along the lines of how can I
embrace and learn to appreciate my body
during
pregnancy um I've struggled with poor
body image and low self-esteem for the
majority of my life and now it seems to
be more
prevalent and I I don't know if you need
background information I feel like it's
pretty straightforward but yeah it
always feels that that way and it never
is
um who told you you're not
beautiful I think I just lived my life
really comparing myself to a lot of
people starting at a young age did
somebody teach you
that you know I don't know I I feel like
it
was I don't know I feel like I'm just
overly critical and I'm the hardest
critic on myself and I know but who
taught you that Kylie why are you
nervous to
say often people who are very very
self-critical were also in charge of
other people's emotions all the time
yeah whose emotions were you in charge
of all the
time I
mean it's say
it I I'm just the oldest of four and so
I feel like it was kind of my job to be
the example to my siblings and
um you can't say you can't say I I I'm
sorry I keep interrupting I know I'm bad
about that you can't even say Mom and
Dad can you I can't because it just I
mean they did so much for me growing up
and I really feel like I had a good
childhood but it's just it's been really
prevalent lately just how critical I am
yeah so I'm going to tell you right now
one of the keys to
being well moving
forward is both
and
okay okay both
and that's going to be your Guiding
Light in the dark moving
forward okay your mom and dad were
amazing and they were also really really
hard on
you and your mom and dad provided you
with meals and a home and college and
all the
stuff and you also had to dance monkey
dance and you knew if I say this dad's
going to get real pissed off and if I do
this mom loses her cool and dad looks at
you and goes why' you make mom mad
you've been in charge of their emotions
forever yeah I think it was hard my dad
worked out of town a lot while I was
growing
up and so I've just gone back and kind
of thought like I just had to kind of be
okay as the oldest and were you your
mom's best friend make things work
um I wouldn't say that but as I got
older I feel like you know I just had to
kind of pick up the slack and help out
around the house
more oh sweetheart you're so
awesome all right I'm gonna give as we
talk I'm going to give you like some
homework assignments will you commit to
doing them yes okay
one of the assignments is I want you to
and this is going to sound so cheesy and
dumb okay okay I want you to draw a
picture and if you have crayons or map
pencils in your house I want you to use
color okay and there's a specific reason
I won't get all nerdy out there's a
reason I want you to draw as Vivid a
picture as possible of you at
12 okay
okay and I want you to be very very
intentional about the things you were
self-conscious of in your body at
12 okay you're too flatchested you were
too busty for a 12-year-old for all your
friends you you're you had too big a
tummy or you were too tall and skinny
whatever the things were that you knew
you were out of bounds on
okay okay and
then with that piece of with that
picture in front of you I want you to do
a free right for 15 minutes I want you
set a
clock and I want you to write
12-year-old Kylie a
letter okay and I wanted to start with
deark Kylie I'm so so proud of
you and I can't
believe you were worried about Fillin
the blank can be very
specific and do you remember that time
mom commented on this or the boy on the
bus commented about this or you had a
boyfriend and he commented about
that okay okay and if you really commit
to it my guess
is there'll be a crack in the facade
you've built because your facade is
incredible you're real
good you've been protecting people for a
long time okay all right so that's step
one all right okay step two is this is
this your first baby first
pregnancy yes and I think that's what
I've struggled with is excuse me my
husband and I we got pregnant quickly
like um and I think I didn't really
mentally prepare myself for all of the
changes and I don't know if you ever can
be mentally prepared but it's just like
not only is pregnancy been hard
physically it's just like the mental
toll of it is also like another level
that I have
experience so is there a chance that the
thing that haunted you as a 12 and 15
and 17 and 19 and 20 year
old when everything just feels too much
that's what your
body automatically defaults to to just
Loop and and cycle on
that that place where you're not enough
you're not enough you're not enough
you're not
enough yeah and it's just so frustrating
cuz I know I am but I feel like I've
just grown up with that cycle that it's
just like no matter what I tell myself
it's like oh but you know you really
you're just saying that to yourself you
know it can't be all true like I know
I'm loved I know I'm valued and
cherished but oh there's no question is
so powerful you know yeah there's no
question the only person that doesn't
believe that is is you yeah everybody
around you can tell you that your
husband loves you doesn't he yes he's
very good to me probably in a kind of a
groy way
[Laughter]
right yeah he's he's been the best and
just so supportive through this too have
you looked at him sometimes and not said
anything but in your mind thought you're
crazy yeah yeah and he's watching you is
how far long are you I'm 14 weeks
okay so you haven't seen a drastic
change
physically um no know what I what I
think what kind of scared me and kind of
initiated this call was I was really
sick my first trimester and actually
between my first and second appointment
lost quite a bit of weight and it just
scared me because initially when I knew
how much weight I lost I was like oh
that's good like I'm losing weight this
is great but then I had to rethink it
and say no like I have another life that
I'm in charge of now that needs
nourishment and you know this is not
good so I think that's what like I just
don't want to have that mindset you know
it's not a mindset how long have you
struggled with
anxiety um you know I've always felt
like I'm a pretty even mellow go with
the flow person but no Kylie no you
haven't I know you haven't but then when
I think about it it's like I am
sometimes not okay like how I deal with
things I just would rather shut down
than like actually deal with stuff and I
really do think I am anxious and it's
it's hard you know it's hard to manage
and
even I don't know it's been a hard
wakeup call for me okay
so I want you for the first time in your
life to consider that the anxiety that
you feel and by the way I believe with
all my guts and intellect that anxiety
and depression are on the same trend
line
okay and your body will try to get your
attention and try to get your attention
and try to get your attention and it
we'll just shut the system
down yeah and does that ring true with
you yeah and I think I just you know try
and shove it down and that's right
because you had to you had to yeah you
basically had a single mom with a drop
in dad and you had three or four little
ones that you were in charge of and you
were in charge of mom and I know you're
like well it was all perfect it wasn't
you know it I know it but you can deal
with that later
and then so your body has been scanning
the environment 247 rapidly and with
great intensity for your whole
life yeah and you may have gotten some
exhale when you found this knuckleheaded
cute boy who said I'll love you forever
and ever and you're like
wooo and then you finally find not not a
voice but you find his presence and he's
close and he's connected and he's strong
and he listens to you and he holds you
and your body maybe for the first time
in your life starts to
go and then damn it you're pregnant
right right after
that and then it's like oh my gosh
what's gonna happen what if there's war
what if climate change is real what if
this what if we're gonna have any money
we're not gonna be able to go to college
college is still GNA be here and and it
just keeps going right yes yeah never
ending Loop honestly I want you to
consider something okay what if your
body body is working
perfectly okay okay what if it's working
for
you what if it is a a mix of experiences
you've had plus genetics plus all these
things that when it sounds the alarms
this is what it feels like and you've
heard me say this a million times on the
show if your smoke detector goes off in
your kitchen it's not the smoke detector
that's the problem it's the fire that's
the
problem and so it may be that you need
to go have go on an expedition a loving
one a curious one not a judgmental one a
huh I wonder why that thing's going off
not a ah it's going off ah I got to
shove it all down until the system
collapses no let's just go look and
see okay okay your body is growing a
human yeah your body is loved by some
boy right do you
work I do okay I don't mean in a gross
way or like in a pervy way but your body
is loved by your workplace they love
that you show up and that you accomplish
a goal and serve customers and take care
of people right yeah and I can just tell
by being on the phone are you a person
that like brings a meal if somebody's
sick yes I I try to be that I know you
are I can tell by the way you talk you
are and you laugh at jokes that aren't
even that funny you probably laugh kind
of loud to help people out is that you
yeah yes okay here's what I want I want
you to treat Kylie like
that
okay and I wish there was another way
word I could give you than what I'm
about to tell you okay you simply have
to
practice believing that Kylie is worth
laughing at her jokes
too you have to believe that Kylie was
worth that boy that grown man telling
God and his family and your family and
you I do
forever come what comes I'll be right
here yeah you see what I'm saying and
the only way you can do that is you got
to practice it and that's a terrible
word I know it's not romantic there's
nothing in the in Hollywood about
practicing you know like getting back in
touch with yourself
right yeah I totally agree with that so
here's how we're going to do that okay
how old are you I'm 23 all right I'm
going to get things all kind of weird
you ready okay yeah I want you to sit
down with yourself first and then you're
probably GNA have to fill in some gaps
with your husband and tell him this is
delon's weird dumb idea and I said I
would do it okay okay I told him and all
21 of his listeners this that he's that
we're going to do this okay okay I want
you to write down 203
things that that make Kylie one of the
most remarkable lovable people on the
planet okay that's so hard it's not it's
not it's
not I'm totally lying it's the worst it
is the worst it is so
hard I don't know if the episode has
aired yet but I talked about this
earlier um after doing some pretty hard
trauma work um with a counselor and
working through some things she finally
nailed me and she was talking about the
ticker tape that is my life and that
ticker tape you know that little thing
that runs underneath the the stock
market on under the news channels that's
always just going or under ESPN she said
your ticker tape just says I
suck I'm the worst all the
time yeah and so she made me ball up my
fist and put it in my chest and I have
to look in the mirror and say the words
I love this
guy and this guy's worth being loved
that's just a thing I repeat
now and I think every you created a a
Persona that makes you so
lovable as a strange protective measure
because you don't buy
it yeah I I feel like that's really
ringing true
okay somebody somewhere told you that
you're worth about what you can how many
kids you can keep quiet
somebody told you that you're lovable
when the report card looks right or when
your body looks right or if your nose is
just perfect or if your bra isn't weird
like somebody told you those things and
you begin to scan the world for them to
make sure they were
true yeah and so most people want to go
fix the body image thing way way down
river I want you to go up
River okay okay because I mean let's
like the objective criteria here you're
losing weight during a pregnancy your
body's growing a human is your baby it
was your was your one try was your
checkup
good yeah I'm really grateful everything
has been normal and I've been better
since that first initial checkin um his
husband being weird and not wanting to
hold your hand and being all like uh can
I just look at Tik Tok no he's he's been
really helpful and
honestly yeah I couldn't ask for a
better partner right now he's super
supportive I don't know how some people
go through this alone yeah it's it's
it's tough but here's the deal the
data
truth is that you're loved
immensely that your body's working
great yeah and by the way when you first
bear the weight of the responsibility of
another life of course your body's going
to be nervous about what happens in the
future of course it would be you'd be
crazy if you weren't you know what I
mean yes you're bringing a human and if
you've made the cardinal sin of Googling
motherhood stuff oh God don't do that
please don't do that you're gonna go mad
yeah there's a whole ecosystem out there
that's designed for one thing to make
you feel guilty and unstable as a as a
about to be new mom and then a new mom
because if you feel guilty and unstable
you'll buy a bunch of crap
I mean that's what it comes down to
you're not doing this right you're not
doing this right you know with how the
motherhood is these days designed to be
it's just really confusing but there's a
great documentary I watched it was years
ago but it was powerful I don't know if
it holds up but it was called The
Business of Being
Born um and I don't even know where it
would show I think I saw it on Netflix
back in the day but I don't know where
it is but it just walked through like
this thing that is so innate to The
Human Experience over gajillions of
years like in the ' 50s became this
really
robust uh medical procedure this surgery
that um had to come with like all the
right rattles in strollers and if you
don't have a million dollars your baby's
G dude madness madness madness of course
there's medical intervention that's
needed and all that yeah but at least at
the time when he talking about I can go
all down a rabbit hole in that one but
just looking at the data and again this
may be eight or nine or 10 years old but
the data on when C-sections are
performed are most often performed at um
doctor's shift changes they want to go
home so it's wild but anyway all I I
tell you this sounds like everything's
working perfectly so it sounds like the
data is right and it sounds like we need
to I'm G say this going to sound so
cheesy and I get it we need to fall in
love with
Kylie what an amazing mom she's going to
be what an incredible wife she already
is what a great big sister she's always
been what an extraordinary employee what
a
great
woman and I know that sounds bananas and
so we're going to practice it so those
things you're going to write them down
every single day of your life for 30
days okay I want you to write them down
and I want you to pause between each one
so it might take you 10 or 15 minutes to
write them all the way down
but I Kylie shows
up Kylie's a person who tells the truth
and always keeps her word kylie seeks
out people who are uncomfortable and
makes sure that they're doing
okay Kylie laughs at dumb jokes just so
people don't feel
embarrassed Kylie answers her mom's
phone calls all the freaking time even
though it stresses her out right all
these things 23 of them we're gonna
write them down every day for 30 days
and then I want you to make a fist and I
want you to put it right in your chest
and I want you to look in the mirror and
say I love this
woman okay and when you do it I want you
to feel your shoulders tense up because
they're going to and I want you to
consciously drop them and say it again I
love this woman she's
good and then by the way your body's
about to do some crazy stuff right yeah
yeah cool we're going to roll with it
we're gonna roll with it that's that's
the part too is like there's no control
over it which like you said it's like
it's amazing and it's beautiful but it's
just that's hey what you're talking
about you just gave me you're talking
about anxiety I can't control it exactly
exactly that's what opening your hands
up and choosing to ride down the river
instead of using every ounce of
everything to trying to swim up River
you're pregnant sister you're having a
baby you're heading down the river now
open your hands up hold your husband's
hand y'all are in this together I'm
going to send you a copy of building a
non-anxious life my number one
bestselling book and I want you and your
husband to use that as a road map for
the next I don't know however many weeks
30 weeks I don't remember how many weeks
you said but and then the first year of
of the baby's life and then the second
year and your marriage is going to
change dramatically and that's all
good you're going to be an incredible
mom you're incred you are an incredible
wife
and when it feels so heavy write it down
and demand evidence is this true and
you're going to drop your shoulders and
smile and go that's not
true I love this
girl I'm a good mom I'm a good wife and
I'm worth being loved
congratulations
Kylie